(upbeat music)
- Yo do you have any lunch plans?
- Yeah actually I was thinking
about getting some fast food.
- Fast food?
- Fast food.
(upbeat music)
- This is the greatest meal I've ever had.
- This is luxury.
(upbeat music)
- Cheap, fast and delicious.
There are literally no
negatives to fast food.
- Zero negatives.
(upbeat music)
(whooping)
I'm gonna be so productive after this.
- This is the greatest
decision we've ever.
(upbeat music)
I am a monster.
- I regret everything.
- It was you, you suggested we get this.
- Sorry I'm sorry.
- I ate what, maybe 60,000 calories.
- Why would you let me do this?
- No one can know about this.
- That was the worst use
of five dollars ever.
- I will never do.
(upbeat music)
Yo do you have any dinner plans?
- Yeah actually I was thinking
about getting some uh.
(upbeat music)